hey guys how's it going I know it's been
a while since my last update but there's
a lot of stuff coming up in the next few
weeks I think you guys should know about
first of all the guys from cyndago
Daniel and Ryan they're actually moving
to LA this Monday so I'm gonna be taking
some time to help them get oriented with
the LA area and move them into their new
place but after that you should see a
lot more sketch comedy stuff coming out
on this channel and me helping them with
sketch comedy on their Channel it's
gonna be a lot of fun and if you don't
know this indigo guys I've made a ton of
sketches with them in the past oh
there's a playlist down the description
below I'll put an annotation up here for
some of the videos that we've done
together I mean they're like I can't
even describe it it's so much fun
because we've learned for so long it's
been about two years now that we've
started working together and we've both
learned or all three of us have learned
so much more in making sketch comedy and
how it's done how it should be done and
and in some ways how it shouldn't be
done but that's even better sometimes so
check it out I hope you enjoy it and I
hope you look forward to more sketch
comedy stuff coming on this channel
because I look forward to making it it's
something that's a passion of mine and
it was the original reason why I wanted
to be on YouTube like it's really close
to my heart and I hope you guys enjoy
what we're going to be making because
we're gonna be making a lot more I hope
to get like a new sketch out if not
every week than every other week I
really want to be putting my whole heart
into doing it and not take away from the
gaming at all I'm still gonna be
releasing two videos a day it's just
that I hope to add onto that sketch
comedy and being on this schedule has
actually helped me because I have a bit
more free time because I always do the
videos ahead of time instead of waiting
to the last minute and that means I'm
able to do more of what I love but also
in addition to that this month I want to
do another charity livestream I'm aiming
for the 21st now all the money from the
previous live streams have now
officially been donated and I'm hoping
to get confirmation letters to show you
guys to be as transparent as possible
that all the money that has been raised
has been donated to the charities
properly I even went down to pax south
and I met with AbleGamers in person to
handle it
the check that we raised I believe those
from The Pajama livestream but uh you
know it's hard to get things mixed up
there was a pajama live streaming the
sweatshirt live stream for living beyond
breast cancer and then there was the
$10,000 at Cincinnati Children's
Hospital and ten thousand dollars to
child's play that went out and I'm
really happy to be able to do those
things and I want to keep doing them
it's just hard with this schedule
because March 6 6 playing on March 6
there's PAX East and not only am i Bob
and Wade going but also yamimash is
going to be in attendance
there's D live and M 2 and who join us
most of the time and also we're really
trying to help get Jack there like I'm
trying to reach out to people to get him
a special guest pass for a media pass
for an exhibitor badge so that he can
get in and you know we can all hang out
together because that's going to be so
much fun i I can't wait because Jack is
one of my favorite youtubers I mean I
don't watch all of his videos but he's
this really really cool guy and I look
forward to meeting him and hanging out
with yamimash again of course like I
can't wait to meet him yet he's just
such a cool guy and I miss him dearly
from the last time I met him in person
at PAX East a year ago which is crazy
like that was a year ago I can't even
believe it like now if you haven't seen
it we did a video while we were at PAX
where we were on these like cushioning
mats and we beat each other with these
big ok this is starting to sound wrong
like one of those marquee bass fan fixes
but not true it's really a lot of fun
and I can't wait to go back again
because some of my best memories are
from when I'm able to meet and be among
my friends again and like if that's
really special to me to be able to do
these things and I sometimes miss it
being out all the way in LA when
everyone is like in the UK or in Ireland
or in Cincinnati or in North Carolina
and you know I'm away from my friends
and family but
the fact that people are moving here and
then I'm able to go out and meet other
people out there is really something I'm
going to cherish a lot and something
that I really really care about because
like I've told you before it is rhetoric
at this point but you know YouTube is a
passion of mine and I love to be able to
entertain you guys but at the end of the
day I'm just one guy who's trying to
stress himself as thin as possible all
over the world and sometimes you know I
think about what has happened over the
course of my life to get me to this
point and I think about the channel and
how it's evolved in now we just hit 5
million subscribers like not long ago
and now we're at almost 6 million in
such a short amount time it just it's
daunting to think about because I've
said it's daunting before when it was
like it a hundred thousand when we hit 1
million I thought it was unreal now
we're like rocketing up and we got a
million subscribers in like a month or
two and it's it's really it's really
hard to keep everything in perspective
but I have to try every day to do so
because I know from meeting you guys
going out to the events it's not just me
hanging out with my other YouTube
friends or real friends in real life
nothing but you did friends aren't my
real friends they are but I also get to
meet you guys and when I was at packed
South it was amazing because I barely
got to spend any time on the show floor
but most of my time was spent just
meeting you guys and it was non-stop
like every second I was there someone
new was coming up to me and I was so
honored that people were saying hi to me
and it was almost overwhelming like I
never wanted to say that it was going to
be to much to meet all of you guys but
to be honest everywhere I went a huge
crowd of people formed and I was like it
was weird because I was honored but I
was also intimidated by the fact that
there was just so many people like when
I went to PAX Prime last year I met
people in a courtyard and that's where
the video with all those people came in
and when I walked I turned the corner
and suddenly like this crowd just
erupted in applause and cheers and it
was at me and I was like holy crap I
just play video games in my room alone
and scream and this is the result of it
like it's it's an intimidating thing but
I I'm truly like honored that you guys
would give me this much love and respect
and I have to cherish it at all points
in my life I have to always understand
that I have a responsibility to give you
guys like everything that I can and I'm
so willing to do it I'm so happy to do
it I'm so happy that I have these
opportunities and I meant this to be a
quick update and goddamnit again every
single you go back every single vlog I'm
like hey this will be a quick update I
love you guys so much you like
everything to me and and I really really
mean it I hope you guys don't think it's
not true I have something in mind but I
really hope you guys don't think that
I've grown numb to any of it because I'm
surprised every day you know I'm
surprised every day at the love and
respect that comes out of this community
and even being of this incredible size
and of course they're bad eggs here and
there but proportionally like they are
insignificant to
like the overwhelming tidal wave of love
that comes out as community every day
and that's that's why I do and that's
why I love to do it and that's why I'll
never do anything else because this is
the most amazing thing in my life I've
said that before I bet but it's true
every time I see so anyway I'll wrap
this up hopefully you got all the
information in between all the
blabbering cuz that's what I am want to
do but I just wanted to say thank you
guys again for supporting me and being
there for me like giving me a reason to
keep moving forward so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the stuff that I linked in the
description below and as always I will
see you in the next video
bye bye